people are putting out four posts per
platform but they're not growing i
actually think it's because almost
everybody produces content from a place
of selfish when i look at the content
i'm like this person could be good but
the only thing they're putting out is
for them to sell their course what's the
recipe the only way to build a personal
brand is to bring value to the decision
makers that has nothing to do with your
direct business let me say this because
it'd be important for a couple of you if
you think about it my audience for
garyvee the last seven years was not
mapping to what vaynermedia was doing
the way you gain credibility is when the
content is bringing value to the
audience when it's not a lead gen for
your business when we read the newspaper
advertorial sections don't get us as
excited as the regular the reason i've
been successful
is i've been able to provide value
without expectation in return of
business and if the karma or serendipity
or if you're friends with the ceo of ge
and you're like you should meet this guy
like the serendipity of the right event
worked out